oui
ce week end à plaisir c'était noël avant
l'heure pour l'association des gâtines
pêche à la ligne
atelier biscuits décorations pour le
sapin les enfants étaient à l'honneur
j'ai fait un bonhomme de neige en sus
klaba
il ya tout sucre et et une pêche est là
et là j'ai fait les choux j'ai fait la
canne à pêche
moi je vais m'occuper du stand de
gâteaux et on s'est relayé avec les
mamans alors chacun participe à un petit
peu ça fait quelque chose de sympa
noël c'est la fête des enfants
auparavant et quelques années on faisait
un marché de noël
et puis on s'est dit que finalement il
fallait avoir quelque chose qui était
beaucoup plus orienté vers les enfants
donc on a décidé de faire une fête de
noël donc avec des ateliers dédiés aux
enfants donc c'est la troisième édition
cette année grande nouveauté 70 écoliers
chante sur scène il fait il aime bien
quand c'est flou c'est qu'on va chanter
60 petit papa noël noël blanc nommant
et quelque chose de rejouer ce rappel et
la fibre artistique semble avoir touché
des enfants de l'école de théâtre de la
ville qui pour leur spectacle de noël se
sont essayés au chant sur scène trente
musiciens ont accompagné plein de trois
enfants l'histoire reprend des légendes
bretonnes quelque part l'idée c'était de
mettre des enfants sur scène avec un
orchestre professionnel derrière et tout
en dotant aussi de costumes par des
professionnels et aussi d'un design de
costumes par un professionnel qui a un
illustrateur breton d'ailleurs soit en
aiguille sont faits graves et comme on
chante pas tous la même chose certains
fonds créés à d'autres aiguë faire
attention à ne pas se mêler les pinceaux
c'est ma cinquième année de théâtre donc
je suis habitué à la scène mais le champ
non plus c'est pas gênant c'est en plus
les chances étaient adaptés à quand je
chantais grave
cette année vous l'aurez compris le
champ accompagnera les fêtes de fin
d'année